backlash building over a new york
city-based psychiatrist saying she
fantasizes about killing white people
during a speech at yale university dr
aruna kilani making those explosive
comments in a guest lecture
to medical students back in had the
april of us loading a revolver into the
head
of any white person that got in my way
gearing their body
and wiping my bloody hands as i walked
away relatively differently
with a diamond myself like
white people are out of their minds they
have been for a long time
we are asking a demented violent
predator
who thinks that they're a state or a
superhero to accept responsibility
it ain't gonna happen they have five
holes in her brain
the psychiatrist claims she was taken
out of context and was speaking
metaphorically
and yale is now backtracking saying in a
statement that those comments are
antithetical to school values but the
university was well aware of the speech
and reportedly restricted online viewing
after
it happened so dana it seems like the
doctor needs a doctor
right so this class that she was
teaching was one that would allow you to
get your licensing credit so it's one of
the ones that you had to take so
this is the kind of thing that is
allowed right so if you wanted to become
a psychiatrist
you could go to this lecture and take
her class i
as i've read that entire interview that
she did with barry weiss and i have to
say like to me
i'm not a psychiatrist obviously but i
was like this person is insane
and the fact that yale tried to suppress
views
like where have we heard that before
right is that censorship like is that
wrong
they knew that it could cause them a big
problem i can't imagine
that they um want this kind of person
there now some people might say
that's just one lady it's just one crazy
it's just one lady and it's not
representative
but when you think about how much we're
all talking in the country about
critical race theory
curriculum that's being suggested for
schools
districts all across the country and
this type of thing is happening at the
universities
then where do they go next yeah right
they graduate
yeah and then come through absolutely
you make the point that you know this is
a class you could take for credits well
that means that you're supposed to take
what she's saying seriously and as if
this is something that
should be credible in terms of an
argument but geraldo basically what
she's saying is
you're allowed to murder white people
for the sake of them being white that
sounds pretty racist to me
[Laughter]
first of all this absolutely uh confirms
my theory that
all psychiatrists are crazy
you just now you just smeared a whole
group basically i did i did i smeared
the whole group
this casual hatred is very very
troubling and it underlies a lot of a
vibe
that's out there right now where you
have to talk about
critical race theory you have critical
race relations going on all over the
place
this one to that one and this one to
that one i think it's very very
troubling
i was a fellow at yale at calhoun
college
named after senator john c calhoun
from you know the early 19th century who
was a racist apparently
john kennedy said he was one of the
great senators ever
but they rediscovered that he was a
racist
uh a few years ago and so they changed
the name of calhoun college
where i was a calhoun fellow and and you
know
i quit i quit because it was so
gratuitous
it was so they were so politically
correct and to to launch
this person and then attempt to cover it
up it's never the crime it's always the
cover-up
they got they got and i say that i have
a
beautiful third year law student at yale
my my daughter i'm very proud
of the association but uh this woman is
uh
is nuts greg yeah i mean uh when dana
said
it is how many minds has she touched
uh that end up in your human resources
department right
or in public relations and the goal
without question is to create a race war
this this language isn't about uniting a
country it's about
splitting it and making sure that it
ends violently
can you imagine having her as you know
she has patience
she actually has could you imagine if
she was your analyst
because she's actually talking about her
white patients
publicly and she was not using their
names but lumping them in
and and describing them as uh
guilt-ridden uh
bread rejecting freaks which is when you
when you when you
generically apply like a certain kind of
identity to a group that's negative
that's racist she was basically
demeaning all of her white patients
imagine how quickly a white md would be
disbarred if he had politically
publicly i'm sorry smeared his black
patients
if he got up there he says you know the
problem with my black patients a b
c and d that person would be a would be
naturally scorned this backlash that
she's experienced experiencing now isn't
even a backlash
yeah it's us talking about it while yale
covers it up
she can by the way in this her defense
about it being out of context what she's
trying to say
is that she once i believe was a person
so consumed with anger
and that she's confessing it now she's
telling you this is how i feel
because i hate white people so much and
that's the context the problem is she
identifies her problem but not the
source
and her source is the obsession with
race the more
people become obsessed with race the
more of this dis
delusion and antipathy and hatred will
spread
and it's it's it's demonic it's actually
when you hear that
you feel the presence it's demonic yeah
true so just i want to make a couple
points so the name of the speech
at yale was the psychopathic problem of
can you the white any other race in
there and insane so what i what concerns
me is you have all these little kids
across america
who are being taught that they're white
supremacists because they're white or
they're racist
because they're white i mean how
destructive is that for little children
number one but what concerns me more is
the democrat party is pushing this
ideology
and they have a long history as racist
segregationists they supported jim crow
and they're doing the same thing here
just in a different way now they've
switched from black and now they've gone
to white but this is the mo of democrats
racism segregation
separation on race and it will destroy
our country yeah
it comes down to identity politics which
is now manifesting itself in a
worse ideology which is critical race
theory all right up next a center in the
sports world hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else